the second day is morning first of all I
want to thank the organizers
for uh this great Workshop they put
together and also giving me this honor
to present our first speaker
um David drewell from
ph.es or ihes
is we have several of fuzz at one point
or another have learned of the DNR
conditions with the rfplr but that is
quite well recognized and there is one
basically a reward in mathematical
physics and character physics including
the boatsman metal then we point three
price and several others it's my honor
and pleasure to introduce
he's going to talk about zeros for
partition functions
please thank you
invited to this place
and I will talk about the Lee Yanks uh
was discovered experimentally by Lee and
yang and they since they are good
mathematicians besides being good
physicists they found the proof but the
proof was not easy and then various
people like Mark cats and um
assignment tried to improve this and
they managed to some extent but not not
a lot and then there was this Japanese
young Japanese person who found a really
simple proof
so this is the reference to Lee Yang and
I made an extension of the Lemma which
is Central to the work of
asano
and I will shall talk about that so here
is the Dilemma
so if you get something out of this
lecture this would be this Lemma so
assume
that you have
by a fine
polynomial
a plus b z one plus c z two plus d z one
Z two where the coefficients are complex
numbers and Z1 Z2 are complex variables
this is separately affine in Z1 and Z2
and assume that this function of Z1 Z2
does not vanish if k
if Z1 is outside of a set K1 and Z2
outside of a set K2 where K1 and K2
are compact
uh are closed subsets
of the
complex plane and do not contain the
origin
then the statement of
the Lemma is that the
the affine function a plus DZ where you
forget uh the terms in B and C
uh a plus DZ does not vanish if Z
is an outside of the set
minus K1 times K2
K1 times K2 is the product of an element
of K1 and an element of K2 so passing
from this
my iPhone function Phi to this Alpha and
function Phi tilde is called asano
contraction
so
let's sit down the the example which was
considered by
I said no himself
if
this polynomial
does not vanish when Z1 and Z2 in
absolute value are less than one
then
the function Phi tilde
does not vanish if
Z is less than one
that's easy to prove and the proof was
given yesterday in fact
if this function
does not vanish when Z1 and Z2
are inside of the unit circle then the
function a plus b z plus c z plus d z
squared does not vanish and this the
roots of this polynomial of second
degree have a product which is minus a
over D and therefore one obtains this
result the case where
and
the set K1 and K2 are somewhat bigger
or different uh
has to be handled separately but you can
imagine that this is a Sim not a very
difficult problem
in fact I
found this result and then
there was a simplified proof by Freeman
Dyson which is the one that is printed
in my paper
okay now Liang
suppose I
have
I denote biases
and
between square brackets the set
one two Etc n
and I consider variables Z1 Z2 ZN and I
shall write z to the power x where X is
a subset of one there n as the product
of the
X Out of the zg where J belongs to X
then
if you have numbers
a j k
which are
real numbers between minus one and one
consider
the polynomial
in
n
variables which is the sum
of the Z to the x of products product
for J in X and K not in X of the a j k
then
the claim is that this polynomial
does not
vanish if all the disease are less than
one in absolute value
now the proof
I I I'll see what it what the proof is
and you will have to think a little bit
to
um check that this is really a proof
I consider the trinomials ZJ Z K plus a
j k z J plus g k plus one
well I I have not mentioned the the
variables at the top and if I take the
product of all these trinomials and make
an asano contraction
of all variables which have the same
name
than I get this polynomial
no I said no contraction
if you have polynomials that do not
vanish inside of the unit circle produce
something that again does not vanish
inside of the unit circle
so
that gives the proof of
the end
ing of the of this result now the Liang
Circle theorem corresponds to the
situation where I take all the zjs equal
to certain variable Z so it's a
polynomial of degree n in one variable
instead of a polynomial of degree one in
N variables and you find that this
result
in a
implies
that
um the polynomial of degree yeah and
in one variable does not vanish inside
of the unit circle
uh by some symmetry
of Z going to one over C
this does not vanish outside of the unit
circle either so it can vanish only on
the unit circle so that is
the Liang circle theoregen and a module
of the fact that you have to make sense
of this little proof this is a very
simple result uh contrary to the
original proof of
Lee and yang
so that's the
which is the Liang Circle
Young
no
come sit down multi are fine complex
polynomials
which are such
that they have this phone and
according to a polynomial
polynomial PSI I Define also upside
dagger
which is obtained by
changing
the
variables
replacing those which are NK by enacts
by those which are outside of act and
taking the complex conjugate
so hmm
we see
that PSY
is a Lee Yang
polynomial
if
when this thing
is less
when z1cn are less than one
PSI
of Z1 to z n is different from zero and
the PSI diagonal is also different from
zero so this is a natural definition in
view of the Liang circles here
incidentally the fact that I look at
multi I find polynomials instead in
invariables instead of
polynomials of
degree n in one variable this was
introduced already in the origin of
proof of Lee and yang so what they
proved is the preliminary theorem that
I'm described
question is it the second polynomial
just the first one we after you divide
by the product of all the X Z's
is the same thing as the first
polynomial this after dividing by the
product of all disease and then taking
complex conjugation yeah
it's a separate condition no
oh
okay
that's a it's not important
okay okay so I mean not necessarily I
mean you you you are probably right that
this is not that this is the same
condition up to dividing by well okay
yeah
Okay so
since these
naughty I find polynomials
are naturally associated with the Liang
circus
and
no
forget about what is on on the screen
my problem one problem that I asked
myself and which was discussed in fact
yesterday is the following
can one generalize the Liang circus
which is a theory which involves
coefficients a j k
to uh
more General
interactions where
and body interactions appear so and I
did not describe the physics of this
thing but the
the polynomial that occur in the Liang
Circle theorem is associated
with it's the partition function of a
spin system in which you have a spin
which can have value zero or one
and
the case dealt with by Lian Yang is a
case of pair interactions now can one
deal with uh and body interactions
instead of
their interactions and the result which
one obtains is that one cannot if one
imposes the Lee Yang condition
essentially the zeros are on the unit
circle
for all values of the temperature so
there is no generalization
of the Liang Circle theorem which holds
for all them for none
their interactions and all temperatures
however as explained yesterday there are
generalizations if one excludes a part
of the temperature range
so that was the talk again yesterday so
the
formal statement is this
if
I mean what what it is essentially is
that
if you have Liang condition at
high temperature then you have the
legion condition at all temperatures so
it may fail
at high temperature if you have non-pair
interactions but not otherwise so
if you have
a Liang polynomial
fire beta for a sequence of beta
standing
like positive values to zero
you have
that it's a Liang polynomial for all
values of beta and furthermore there
exists
real numbers w j k
AJ
and complex B's such that
wjk is equal to w k j
and
the
W which occurs in this formula
so that is the WR essentially the
logarithm of the coefficient of this
wealthy affine polynomial they must have
this form which says in effect that you
have pair interaction and in fact
ferromagnetic there
interactions because you have this
condition that the w
JK uh symmetric and
have a positive value
so
that is the generalization
also required to be positive
or easier
that not required to be a non-negative
of being required to be non-negative
these questions are none negative or
let's see if well that's uh
say they they are fine at the the
so
could they be because
we see they must be exponential of
something which is finite or they cannot
be zero
foreign
okay so uh that's all I find but this is
wrong based on the asano form of this
Lemma
and the generalization which I produced
which
is
that the set
okay I'm not necessarily the outside of
the unit
Circle
does this bring something useful
to physics and the fact is that there
are
iterals one to deal with some
polynomials in melty I find polynomials
which
oh growth graph counting for the
nominals
so
a graph is a and what I call a graph is
a finite graph undirected and where
there may be multiple edges between uh
the vertices
and I associate variables with
the
address so in the previous
version in fact I associate in variables
with the vertices now I associate the
variables with the
edges and suppose I have
a
set of sub graphs so let f
curly F be a set of sub graphs I Define
a polynomial
polynomial associated with the set of
sub graphs as the sum over the same
graphs of in question of Z to the power
F Well Z to the power f is the the
product
of the variable Z
e associated with the edges in the sub
graph
now we can
obtain in the obvious way a polynomial
of degree
n
in one variable
by making all these variables z e equal
to a variable Z and this is then the sum
over the sub graphs in question of
Z
to the power the number of edges in the
same graph
so this is the sub graph counting
polynomial
associated with the family
of
seven graphs now there's one
simple family of seven graphs which one
can think of which is the sub grass such
that
each
so that the Suncraft so so that two
adjacent edges cannot be occupied
simultaneously so these are
let me go back to that later so these
are the dimer
several crafts so
I've got a subgraph counting polynomial
which counts diamonds is then simply the
sum over Diamond sub graphs of
Z to the power
the number of edges occupied by
uh the dino
seven crime and
there is a theorem
of Hyman Lieb which says that the zeros
of
this polynomial of such a polynomial
must
be real
negative
a paper of iron rib contains many other
results but in particular this result
and
the
fact is that it is
an easy
consequence
of the
of the Asana oil Lemma
suppose
for each
vertex V
I hide
are fine polynomial which is one plus
the sun over
e
in the
uh
in the graph
with one point
one
so
you make a sum of our edges
in the graph
such
that
one
extremity of the edge is in fact V so
this is because there can be only one
Edge ending at each point this is a fine
function
no hmm
the notion
is that
if you make a product
of
such
a fine
probably no meals overall
vertices
of
the Dove and then make an Asana
contraction
of
the variable Z
with one
and
V and one end at some other point then
you get uh
multi assigned polynomial which counts
the
Diamond sub caps
is that clear
okay so
the problem now is uh
can one say something
about this
multi-assign
polynomials
no hmm
what one will have to do
is considered
a region
such that this
are fine
polynomial does not vanish
and
uh
consider
the the various regions associated with
these
um
things now let me
oh
foreign
and take
something some half plane
which
does not contain zero but contains the
negative
numbers so if
so this is close to zero but not quite
zero if you take
points which are in this half plane
and multiply them by points which are in
the same half plane you get in fact
the outside
the
outside of a
habola
it's a fact of the geometry of
the complex plane
that
taking
a line and multiplying by itself you get
a parabola and
so if you have something which does not
vanish in this region then the
contraction
of two
variables
just give something which does not
vanish in the
inside of this Parabola so there's a
little bit of geometry of the complex
plane that comes in in this but that's
not very hard to prove no
I have taken
uh
line a half plane of this so you can
modify this half plane take a different
half plane and what you find is that
if you have
something
variables which lie on
a straight line of various a variable
an inclination
you get something which
by after no contractions is not zero so
what happens is
you have
a multi-afine polynomial associated with
diamonds that does not vanish
if all
the variables are along a line which
turns around this way and in fact you
must avoid the negative real axis
so
nothing all variables
equal to variable Z what you find is
that you have a polynomial the
diamond counting polynomial
which does not vanish
outside of the negative
Creole
axis
so this is a new proof and perhaps
simpler the further result of
Harman Lieb yeah
we'll say in the monomer dimer case
because the important thing in how
common lip was the bond not just the
fact the roots are yield also provided
the bound
well it does give a bond in the sense
that you
have some
you start with the graph which has a
finite number of edges ending at each
point and you take the maximum number of
edges that can end at a point and this
will give you
a estimate of where
along the negative real axis can be
yeah
boots
okay so that's uh that's very nice to be
able to prove or see how much has
already been proved by someone else
but the the uh
is you would like to prove something new
and uh
then
the new I think that
I can say that was the case
of
also so that's the harmony
in the case of unbranched subgraphs so
unbranched sub graphs are some graphs
such that every
uh vertex can be a common point of two
edges of the sub graph
but not more than two zero one or two
so uh and rank sub graphs are
topologically either circles
or a straight line a straight line
intervals
and um
then
the notion is that
um
you
can again obtain
the subgraph counting
polynomial for unbranched sub graphs by
asano contractions with
of a product of things which
correspond to choosing an individual
vertex and so the
for each individual vertex you will have
a second degree polynomial with
something which is a constant term plus
a linear term plus a second degree term
which corresponds to pairs of
actions that can
meet at
the
vertex in question
and then you have to get a
you you have to start with the fact that
such polynomials will not vanish in a
certain region
no it so happens that there is a
theorem
that says that if you take that if you
have polynomial which is symmetric
in
multi I find polynomial which is
symmetric in its arguments
uh and if it does not vanish
well if taking all the arguments equal
you get some re aching in which some
circular region in which this does not
vanish
then
it also does not vanish when you take
all the variables to be
different
so that
famous uh
so-called and so what one has to do is
to look now at
a second degree polynomials
in one variable
and of a certain particular form which
corresponds to uh
well let me you can imagine what it says
it says that at a given point there can
be either zero Edge or one Edge so
that's a n
Z and R2 Edge and that is n n minus 1
over 2 Z squared and you have to find
out when this uh does not vanish and uh
it so happens that
um
this polynomial
does not vanish
in a region
which
in the complex plane is an edge like
this 45 degree
so it doesn't finish when the things are
in this so if you take any line
this you will have
the possibility to
take
Z in this in in one side of this line
and you can turn this line
so that it goes this way or this way so
when you
do
the calculation which is in fact not
hard what you find is that the
of the
seventh half
Counting
polynomial
unbranched sub graphs
in fact
does not vanish in the right half plane
so that
satisfactory result
can one get something out of this and
the fact is that number of years after
this result was obtained which at the
time was a moral satisfaction that one
could prove something for a class of
sub cards different from the diamonds
and crafts that
one signs
a result that under
oh the wide
um
conditions on the original graph say
that it's ZN for finite n and take the
the edges joining
um
neighbor neighboring point
then and take a subset of that that
tends to Infinity in an appropriate
manner like some big circle then one
obtains the result that the
distribution of coefficients
of the
of this polynomial
is asymptotically gaussian
uh the the proof is complicated and uh
involves a number of results that I
cannot talk about many people in this
audience probably know these results
better than I do but let me give you uh
intuitive idea of why this could be true
so take a polynomial which has take a
heal polynomial in fact with positive
coefficients that
does not vanish in the right hand have
plane
then you can write this polynomial as a
product of either linear polynomials
corresponding to
root on the negative real Axis or a pair
of complex conjugate
numbers which are in the left half plane
and the corresponding
second degree facto which this
corresponds to has positive
coefficients
no okay
then
assume and that's a real assumption but
it's it's a natural idea that these
factors are in fact
independently distributed
so the the the factors of the
uncrenched counting polynomial is um
for the the factors um
a second degree or first degree things
with
positive coefficients and suppose these
are independent
independently distributed then going I
mean to
assemble instead of a product this means
that there will be a gaussian
distribution
and that's as far as
you know but it makes it natural
that the condition that the zeros are
in the negative real
in the negative complex plane this is
natural because if you had a pair of
positive
with positive real part then this would
give
a factor which is not which does not
have positive coefficients
Okay so I'll stop there thank you
[Applause]
any questions
you may ask historical question
so I wanna ask a historical question
so have you tried when you do deals with
monomer dimer on desktop have you tried
to attack Wonder Garden conjunction for
the permanent I I don't you you will
have to remind me of what okay
no I I've known it but I've forgotten it
but as usual we have a break until 10 30
so feel free to approach Dr Wells
closer in person and ask him
thank you